it's the night of October 5th 2018 so
it's time for me to do another monthly
update video in which I'll talk about
what we've got coming up in October and
what went on in September both quite
busy months for me I always like to
begin by highlighting three big things
so with no further ado big thing number
one is that tomorrow here in Milwaukee
we have a stoical week event coming up
which I'll talk about once we get to the
October section big thing number two is
that while I was at Stough account which
I'll talk about in the September part I
got for interview videos shot hopefully
the footage is quite good and big thing
number three I'm hoping this month to
actually start bringing out some new
teachable classes in our reason IO
Academy and to start updating some of
the class material available in in those
classes as well all right what went on
in September very very busy month I'll
talk about classes and I should mention
as well that I was preparing for stoic
weak and stoic Khan in London as a
member of the modern stoicism
organization there's a lot of work
preparatory to these events and that I
gave two sessions of a workshop that I
had built with my wife and II Chaka who
was unable unfortunately to to fly out
to snowicon' on stoicism and partnered
relationships called the stoic heart so
that went quite well and and between
that and the classes I've been kept
extraordinarily busy in September I did
do quite a few online events
my regular Hagel Q&A and discussion
sessions philosophy pop-ups philosophy
chat the ask me anything session and
then unfortunately due to illness I had
to cancel my worlds of speculative
fiction session which was due to be on
Jean wolf and the book of the New Sun
this month but it has been put off to
December so we will be doing that this
year
and I also did a short presentation on
Hildegard of Bingen very interesting you
know not quite high Middle Ages German
Abbess philosopher musician theologian
and you know I did that presentation and
like I mentioned that stoic and stoic on
itself was a really great conference
it's always wonderful to get together
with the the people who are presenting
and providing workshops and the members
of the modern stoicism organization and
all of the other people who come who are
connected with various stoic
organizations or meetups or blogs or
podcasts it's you know like any other
con it's it's a place where the people
who are really interested in that sort
of thing
come and there were about 330 attendees
put together that with all of the other
people you know doing work behind the
scenes or presenting and it was about
350 people so that was an excellent
excellent conference I mentioned that I
have classes going on I'm currently
teaching one class for the Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design which is
about ten blocks to the south east of
here and I'm also teaching two classes
for Marquette University about ten
blocks to the west of here
and so that's kept me quite busy I've
been doing you know a lot of editing
work for stoicism today's we get you
know got ready for stoical week and a
little bit of writing of my own
not as much as I would have liked I
spent a lot of time involved with
clients in tutorial sessions
philosophical counseling some ethics
consulting with with international
clients as a matter of fact the work
that I've been doing I think this last
month had me connected up with people on
five different continents
so that's that's that's quite a lot I
was also on the money savage podcast and
I'll put a link to that episode I was
one of the first returned guests on that
podcast so that's that's pretty cool and
I did get some video work done not quite
as much as I would have hoped I didn't
get my half-hour Haegele videos done and
I've even got people like emailing me
and asking me hey you're gonna keep
doing the series and the answer is yes I
am going to get back into that release
some videos that I'd shot on Kierkegaard
and released to my patreon supporters
earlier
I've been publicly releasing those some
Aristotle politics videos as well and
podcast episodes I did some podcast
episodes on Cicero's stoic paradoxes and
Epictetus discourses so that was the
month of September alright so what have
we got coming up in the month of October
it's going to be quite a busy month for
a lot of different reasons some of which
I'll talk about more in just a minute
and let's talk about events first so
tomorrow in the afternoon here in the
Milwaukee area that tomorrow that is
October 6th at 3:30 p.m. we have a
stoical week event I'll be talking on
stoic philosophy and the value of money
what role money can play in happiness or
in relation to the virtues or in
relation to our emotions I won't say too
much about that and I will hopefully get
a good video recording of that so I'll
post that online for those who aren't in
this area on Tuesday the 9th
I will be making another guest
appearance on the image for hire radio
show hosted by River West radio with our
host being the skräuss he and I will be
talking about HP Lovecraft
and probably will talk about August
Derleth as well since he played a major
role in the continuation and
dissemination of Lovecraft's works and
he was based here in Wisconsin on the
11th at the Brookfield public library
7:00 p.m. we continue our worlds of
speculative fiction series this time
looking at the Alliance Union universe
CGH era some really great books there
starting with down below station really
interesting stuff then on the 13th at 12
o'clock p.m. that Central Standard Time
I will be hosting the dr. Sandler asked
me anything that is am a session at the
same day at 2 o'clock I will be having
my philosophy chat for patreon
supporters on the 16th at 3 o'clock p.m.
will start shifting into Hagel gear with
our public Hagel Q&A online session so
if you've got any questions about Hagel
German idealism Hagel successors his
influence you can show up and I'll give
priority to anybody who wants to ask
questions or raise issues or comments
then we also have a follow up to that on
the 20th at 12 p.m. that's just for my
patreon supporters of the half of our
Hagel project we always get some lively
discussions in those on the 24th I'm
going to be down at Rockford University
we don't have all of the date the times
that we do have the date set I will be
giving some talks to students there
although you can come in as a member of
the public and also hear me talking I'll
be talking about stoic philosophy
we're not quite sure at this point
exactly what talks I'll be giving at
exactly what times but if you look at my
Facebook page you will you will see me
post them there finally another local
event we have our monthly meeting of the
MKE stoic fellowship on the 25th at 6
p.m. so it's quite a lot of things going
on I'm like I mentioned I'm teaching
three classes already face to face and
believe it or not I'm taking on an
additional two with two other
institutions one I've been teaching for
quite a while for Maris College that's
my world views and values class and
that's always a lot of fun and I'm
starting teaching with another place
here locally just a few blocks from here
called Milwaukee Area Technical College
but the class that I'm teaching is an
online intensive seven week ethics class
so we've got that going on still you
know continuing my work with clients
with tutorials and philosophical
counseling ethics consulting got a lot
of interesting projects going on hoping
that I'm going to get to some more
writing both in blogs and in terms of
book projects and academic work as well
this month and I'll also be doing quite
a few podcast guest spots I actually was
on a morning show just yesterday talking
about stoicism and I as soon as I get
the sound file for that I'll post that
as well
as far as video work goes so I've got
more kierkegaard videos to release and I
also have when it comes to those core
concept videos some Cicero videos that I
shot for my students and I'll be
releasing all of those to my patreon
supporters within the next week but I'll
be sort of trickling them out over the
course of the month to everybody else I
got a lot of video footage of interviews
so you can expect to see a couple of
those coming
I do want to get to a few book review
videos this month and I also really need
to get back into the half hour Hegel
videos so I'm gonna start cranking those
out getting back into that this month as
well
podcast there's a lot of epictetus
material that I'm going to be editing
maybe some other material I'll throw in
there here and there but that'll
probably the be the bulk of what it is
that I'm working on at the present so
that is what's coming up for this month
you can tell it's quite a lot and
hopefully I'll get to all of it hope all
of you have a great month and I hope I
see some of you in these online or
face-to-face events and if you're
somebody who routinely watches my videos
just come up and introduce yourself to
me and I'm always happy to to meet
people who enjoy talking about
philosophy
you